before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
between this and Rosa
is Chipmunks are the one that did the
most American set historical episodes
huh
[Music]
Nikola Tesla's Knight of Terror so this
is an episode that
honestly in terms of my memory kind of
went in one ear and went out the other
it didn't really stick with me at all
either in a good way or a bad way so my
memory of it was basically that it was
forgettable
and that kind of became my memory by
default I couldn't remember
a ton of my thoughts on it I could
remember the episode overall I could
remember the characters who showed up I
remember the monsters but like in terms
of how any of that made me feel
the lingering feeling was just like that
that was fine
and it is but it's a little bit better
than that there's more going on in this
presentation than I think I've given it
credit for up to this point it's not
some kind of overlooked gem that a lot
of people are sleeping on or anything
like that but
it just left a better impression when I
was really kind of focusing in already
knowing what it was and looking for the
strong and the weak points and there
aren't that many weaknesses and there's
a decent number of strengths not
epically amazing strengths but strengths
nonetheless and sometimes just a solid
piece of entertainment is what you're
after and this gives you that why don't
we start with the guest cast I actually
really like Nikola Tesla as portrayed by
Goran vizinjick
probably just butchered that but he does
a really good job he does an excellent
job of bringing through performance the
idea of how excited but also kind of
worn down he is the man had so many
ideas so many Notions thoughts ways to
improve the world but he was just not
given the opportunity and the resources
he needed and you can get both that
excitement and that frustration which is
nice to see both in the same place
because the lazy way to play this is to
have it be like a switch on and off he's
either really excited or he's completely
jaded but we see both in play at the
same time and that's that's pretty well
done I also like how Thomas Edison is
handled now Edison is not a good guy in
this like at all and I would say kind of
rightfully so Edison is a very important
figure but I don't think there's any
real problem with uh painting him as a
little bit of a Sinister one and a bit
of an exploitative one at that because
what the episode shows not inaccurate
there were tons of patents with his name
on them how many of them he actually
came up with or worked on that's more
debatable it makes that distinction
between inventor and businessman Edison
was an amazing businessman and he was an
inventor but he couldn't hold a candle
to Tesla but Tesla Tesla didn't know
business he didn't he wasn't willing to
play that game and he lost as a result
because when it's a capitalist system
you don't get to just opt out of playing
that game that's the game you play or
you lose by default which is kind of
what happened to him but I don't think
for the demonizing that goes on with
Edison they don't completely go as hard
as they could have so like for example
when a whole bunch of his uh his
researchers in his own lab get killed by
the aliens he does Express genuine
remorse people have died my workers
all those men work for me they had
families I had dinner with this guy and
his wife last week it does show him to
be a human being we're not going to the
extreme of say the capitalist character
in thin ice who being not a real genuine
person was actually pretty fair to just
straw man the heck out of him for the
purposes of the point that episode was
making but they're not doing that with
Edison because they're like yes he takes
advantage of people but that doesn't
mean that he is completely inhuman in
his view of the people who work for him
is he taking advantage of them well yeah
absolutely it doesn't mean he doesn't
see them as people and again that feels
nicely balanced he's not a good guy but
he's not a monster we do have monsters
though we have the skithra which I don't
love as a name
um but they're basically an alternate
version of the rachnos which I don't
think ever actually gets said in the
episode which actually it's kind of
funny there's a bunch of stuff this
episode doesn't do that it's better for
it so like for example it does not at
least in my memory explicitly make the
connection between the ragnos and the
skithra if it is it's a very throwaway
line and it makes it something that is
just there for people who know more of
Doctor Who to go oh they must be related
to this this is like the Scorpion
environment the ragnos for the spiders
but if you don't like it doesn't impact
your ability to enjoy this story I I
appreciate that the uh the scithra queen
obviously had a much easier time
speaking uh with those teeth than the
ragnos queen did and thank goodness too
because
look the rachnos visually was amazing
but listening to her talk like this like
oh it took me out of every scene we're
not dealing with that here and I another
thing I appreciate is the episode does
not do the super explicit let's sit down
and point out to Edison how he is like
them because the skithra are running a
ship that is cobbled together from stuff
that other people made but they use and
get the benefits of so there's a very
clear parallel between them and Edison
it's not a one-to-one but there's strong
parallels there
and the episode doesn't sit down and
stop the story in order to point that
out
it respects the audience enough to make
that connection which is nice especially
given that series 11 especially had a
tendency to basically sit either the
characters or the audience down and like
kill the momentum to lay out here's the
themes here's the real life background
on this character and look like there's
some of that we get some of that
information on Tesla but honestly even
though it is very much still
expositional dialogue it's delivered
better these feel much more like
statements people might actually make
yes it's still Exposition but it's not
like King James and witch finders who
just vomits his Wikipedia bullet points
out or Rosa where it literally stops to
actually have a lesson but we still get
the core information for people who
might not know who Nikola Tesla is but
in a way that just flows better it's
just refined it's less clunky if you
still have a problem with expositional
dialogue you might solve a problem with
this but as someone who is willing to
accept that to a certain degree
especially in something as long as an
episode of Doctor Who is sometimes you
need to do it and this is decently done
I also feel like this episode has a
little bit more respect for life one of
the things that ended up being a
recurring issue for me across series 11
was that the episodes could feel cruel
and how callously people got killed and
how little acknowledgment there was of
it when that happened and it just felt
mean-spirited to me uh the decent chunk
of the time here while there is
definitely a body count here as I said
the skither wiped out like an entire
room of people we have someone like
Edison expressing like this is horrible
what happened someone who actually knew
them and seems to feel genuine remorse
so there's more weight to put on the
desks that are there there's a number of
characters that I feel like if this was
done in series 11 would have been killed
but aren't here people like uh Tesla's
assistant who might also have just been
spared because she might have been a
real life person I didn't check that but
like also later on there's this kid in
the street and I would not have put it
past series 11 to kill well maybe not
kill that kid but like to have whoever
was the person in the street just get
killed like for no reason we've
established that the scithra are deadly
we don't need to re-establish it but I
could totally see series 11 just killing
whoever that was in this case it doesn't
maybe it doesn't because they picked it
to be a kid but either way there feels
like there's more acknowledgment of
death and there's less callousness and
just like oh somebody died move on and
that's nice given that that was a little
bit of a recurrent issue for me the last
series if there's one thing that I
it's not the worst thing in this episode
but I'm gonna point it out because it's
something that's going to come up with
some issues that I have with later
episodes so I want to kind of set it up
here
when uh Tesla sort of floats the idea or
a willingness to turn himself over to
the skithra basically saying like look
what they're going to do is horrible I
am willing to turn myself over it
bothers me a bit that the doctor's
rationale for telling him he can't do
that is because he's going to change
history
go
and take me that's not gonna happen no
Nicholas Tesla
You're Gonna Change the World now that's
not necessarily her only reason she does
go on a bit but like that's the first
thing she points out
it's like the fact that he is one of the
great men of history is the overriding
reason to not let him do this as opposed
to just you know he's a human being and
no human being should just be turned
over to have whatever the scith we're
going to do to him happen to them and
that troubles me and again it's got It's
a bit of a setup for a later episode but
that troubles me because
by putting that emphasis on how
important he is to history
that makes it feel like she might not
have gone to this extent to save
somebody who wasn't him
and I like to think she still would
but I don't like that it's presented in
a way that leaves even the possibility
that that might be the case
like and and I get he's important I'm
not trying to make an argument that he
isn't but in my mind that should not be
the doctor's go-to point as to why you
don't turn somebody over to aliens you
don't turn somebody over to aliens
because every life matters you shouldn't
have to point out that this life in
particular is uh super super special
and as time has gone on I have
increasingly had a just a negative gut
reaction to
um I don't know if this is what it's
actually called but what I tend to think
of as the great man uh view of History
which is how at least when I was in
school most history is taught you're
taught about Kings Emperors rulers
generals the people who are recorded by
history and to a certain extent that
can't be helped because those are the
people that we have the best Records On
but at the same time it paints a image
of history as being driven by the
actions of a handful of very special men
because of the patriarchal nature of
most of the civilizations that have kept
any decent records at all
they have been ruled by men so there's
better records on them and it creates
this illusion that there are the great
men and then there's everyone else
and that's not necessarily deliberate in
the way that history is taught but it is
something that is kind of a Fallout of
the way history tends to be taught the
reason I bring all this up here is
because a show like Doctor Who
has the ability because it is setting
stories actually in the past so that
while we are meeting great figures of
History they are not all that we meet
it has the opportunity and the ability
to make the point that no it's not just
about a handful of quote-unquote Great
Men
unfortunately the show rarely takes
proper advantage of that we have some
stories that do I'll bring up thin ice
again which doesn't really have a
prominent historical figure in it at all
it's about the setting and the
environment that existed at that point
of time and that's kind of what I wish
Doctor Who would do more often as
opposed to focusing in historical set
episodes around a single important
person
so it's just it the the pointing out I
mean the structure of the thing at all
but especially the pointing out like we
can't let anything happen to you because
you matter too much
feeds into that entire mentality
and it just bugs me and just to tangent
for a quick second just to make my point
I'm going to give you a name that you
should know but probably don't
Frank Wills
Frank Wills was the security guard at
the Watergate complex who noticed tape
over a latch and a door and first
reported it and that's what broke open
the entire Watergate scandal so even
though Watergate is remembered as being
a Nixon thing there are many people
involved and the whole thing was
discovered because of the actions of
someone who would never be labeled as a
great man of History
normal people matter
and that's something that I wish Doctor
Who Would acknowledge more and I know
I'm dwelling on this but again it's
because I know this is gonna be a bigger
problem for me down the road
but we'll get to that when we get there
overall
um there's a rocking Adventure feel to
this that I just like I like when doctor
who goes for that tone in that field so
it's well paced it's well acted the
exposition's better delivered it just
feels more refined it's not a million
miles away from the historicals of
series 11 but it just feels more
polished and it kind of shows that a lot
of the bones of what was in series 11
weren't bad inherently they just needed
a little more work and this feels like
the product of a little more work
I like it I think it went up a little
bit in my estimation not massively but a
little
Nikola Tesla's night of Terror have you
rewatched it lately what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living it also gets you early access to
these videos up to a week before they
Premiere publicly any amount that you
help me will get you that perk and
there's other perks besides but even if
you can't like share subscribe help me
out as well don't worry too much about
that either because what I really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toy lowly Becky Sparks for nabilox the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]